everyone knows chocolate is toxic for
dogs but do you know which chocolate is
the most dangerous we're going to answer
that for you in today's pet vet segment
with dr jamie ogenstein of oasis animal
hospital in henderson earlier this month
she tackled xylitol which is found in
sugar-free gum and it can be deadly to
your dog today she's covering chocolate
other foods even medication
everyone knows chocolate is toxic
but it's in different gradations so you
have your
least ch toxic is going to be your milk
or your white chocolate sorry your white
chocolate and then milk chocolate is a
10 fold increase from that from there is
going to go dark chocolate
then your baker's chocolate and cocoa
those are your most dangerous and it's
not a simple
one two three four times it's a tenfold
100 fold a thousand fold increase in
toxicity so the stronger the cocoa bean
the exponential toxicity level there is
so chocolate is toxic
grapes and of course grapes when you
dehydrate them become raisins we'd still
have don't know why grapes are toxic but
they are and
um
there's there's stories of cases of pets
getting one or two and becoming poisoned
and other cases where they get more and
they don't get become poisoned so we
don't know why we don't understand it so
we just say stay away from them
um
garlic
actually it people will sometimes use it
for flea prevention it doesn't work but
in excess garlic can actually cause
red blood cell problems and same thing
with onion now it takes quite a bit but
it can actually be quite dangerous if
people are cooking and they're seasoning
with garlic and onion and then they
share their food
pets can definitely get enough that it
can cause problems wow so grapes raisins
chocolate
garlic onions
and then xylitol is a big one there's
some nuts out there there's a few other
things and so you just have to be very
careful with what pets can eat not
everything is safe for them
even medications ibuprofen never give to
a cat tyler tylenol never give to a cat
ibuprofen never give to a dog
tylenol you can give to a dog but you
better know that dose
same thing with aspirin you need to know
the proper doses so don't just
dose them like you would for a kid or a
person